one out of every seven adults in the U.S
has some level of kidney disease but
many of those individuals aren't even
aware of their condition March is Kidney
Health Awareness Month and here was some
important information is Dr Rahul devroy
of Intermountain Health the sponsors of
this segment thank you for being here
doctor again well thanks so much for
having me
what can people do to if they don't know
whether they have a kidney condition
that's a little disconcerting to think
that so many people may have this and
and are not doing anything to take care
of it in general kidney disease affects
like you said almost 15 percent of
Americans now there's a slight
disconnect one out of seven Americans
has this but only one out of ten can
really identify that they or know of
that they have this problem now why is
that well one of the initial problems
with it is that the initial presentation
of kidney disease can be totally
asymptomatic or silent because of this
it's important to screen for kidney
problems in general now even though
people may be able to function at a high
level the damage is still being done in
the background even though they can't
feel it because of that screening for
kidney problems is very important
kidneys have a large role in how the
entire body functions so if there is a
kidney disease it could affect so many
aspects of one's health absolutely so in
general the kidneys I like to think of
them almost like the filters of the body
they have many different roles including
making our urine managing our
electrolytes working with our bone
health our blood pressure control and
they also interact with a lot of of our
other vital organs such as our heart and
our liver in order for us to maintain a
balance because of this just like you
said if enough damage accumulates over
time this can lead to a variety of
different problems down the line yeah
The Chronic problems what could that
lead to absolutely so unfortunately due
to other chronic medical conditions such
as high blood pressure diabetes the
kidneys are very sensitive to these
issues over time this could lead to
what's called chronic kidney disease
leading to damage in the kidneys that
occurs now it's important to check and
screen for these things because we all
may have either met someone or know
someone who is on dialysis this is kind
of a severe form and kind of the end
stage renal diseases we like to call it
so in order to prevent that checking
early and preventing this progression of
the disease into chronic kidney disease
is important so what can one expect if
they decide to get screened for kidney
disease absolutely so screening is
really the key for the game we can it's
important to establish with a primary
care doctor so that they can check your
blood works and urine studies as well to
make sure we find where on the Spectrum
you may lie it's also important to note
that just because you have some degree
of kidney problems it doesn't
necessitate that it'll always progress
to chronic kidney disease or end-stage
kidney disease the whole point of
prevention is to catch it early so we
can stop it before it really gets more
serious so with your general
practitioner when you're going through
any blood test or urine analysis that's
the time to say hey let's make sure also
that we're being we're screening our
kidneys absolutely as a private or care
physician screening begins with just the
regular routine blood work instead of
writing it off I like to engage in
discussions with my patients to make
sure they understand why we're doing it
even if the tests are normal so checking
regular blood work making sure not only
helps us prevent but also gives us this
time point so if this year for example
your blood work looks good and next year
it's abnormal we can hey we can see
what's happened in this past year and
have somewhat of a chronologic order to
know when this disease is great
information and we hope everybody goes
out and gets screened for it thank you
very much Dr devroy thanks so much for
having me Kendall thanks again to
Intermountain Health for sponsoring this
segment visit
intermountainnb.org for more information
we'll be right back